oh we have to mention this from the
daily wire Twitter indicated Tuesday
afternoon that they are moving forward
with letting Elon Musk acquire the
company after the billionaire
entrepreneur informed the company in a
letter that he wanted to proceed with
the purchase for the original offer of
54. and 20 cents per share musk made the
proposal in a letter to Twitter
Executives which sent share prices
surging by as much as 22 percent
the company said a statement Twitter
issued this statement about today's news
we received the letter from musk parties
which they have filed with the SEC the
intention of the companies to close the
transaction at 54.20 per share
uh Twitter had been battling musk and
Cordova's attempt to cancel a previous
offer to buy the company for 44 billion
dollars must Express concern that the
actual share of fake accounts on the
platform could range as high as 33
percent rather than the company's
reported five percent so
so anyway he was trying to get out of it
but it seems like he realized that he
was going to lose in court and so now
now Elon Musk is being forced to
purchase this multi-billion dollar
company which I mean this is like the
kind of problem you can only have if
you're the richest man in the world
you're being forced to purchase a
multi-billion dollar company
um maybe unfortunate for him works out
great for the rest of us I mean I
couldn't be happier about it
um
because it seems as though Elon Musk is
actually going to take over Twitter
and I am just going to go
crazy on Twitter with the misgendering
I'm going to be misgendering everybody
all over the place
and I I'm very excited for that now
there are two reactions to this that I
want to note kind of representative of
the of the whole
so first this is from
Ben Collins who's a senior reporter for
NBC News
and he obviously is very upset about
this
and he says for those of you asking yes
I do think this site can and will change
pretty dramatically if musk gets control
over it no there is no immediate
replacement if it gets done early enough
based on the people he's aligned with
yes it could actually affect the
midterms
if musk is really taking this site
private there are no real guard rails
anymore rule making can be capricious he
can Elevate any idea or person he wants
through recommendations and ux choices
and there will be no oversight on this
as a private company
this is great for a few reasons first of
all he's ba he's admitting that Twitter
suppresses and censors and does it to
help the Democrats in the midterms and
what that means is that if they're not
able to do that anymore then it will
affect the midterms and it will be worse
for the Democrats
but I also love how he says that that
well when musk takes over
there's rule making will now now all of
a sudden rule the rules on Twitter will
be arbitrary and capricious
yes I can only imagine it's it's you
know that's that's it's hard to imagine
a scenario where Twitter or any other
social media company would have
arbitrary and capricious rules
that are enforced unfairly and unevenly
targeting certain groups of people while
letting others off the hook
can you imagine that I can't
nothing like it has ever happened
I also can't imagine this from Robert
Reich
uh Berkeley Professor he says
when multi-billionaires take control of
our most vital platforms for
communication it's not a win for free
speech it's a win for oligarchy well
once again
uh I also cannot imagine this I cannot
imagine
billionaires owning social media
companies this will be the first one
Elon Musk will be the first billionaire
it's kind of maybe it's breaking a glass
ceiling in a certain way he's going to
be the first billionaire apparently
really the first rich guy
to own a social media platform before
this all the social media platforms were
were owned by Working Class People they
were owned by you know like plumbers and
they were owned by Working Class People
you know Facebook Instagram
tick tock
even Twitter prior to this
the the Twitter board consisted of I
guess I don't know School teachers and
uh electricians and people who work at
Walmart
is what we're supposed to believe which
of course is totally absurd if you want
to join my exclusive fan base or a cult
as really as that's what it is or Joy
we're forming a cult then all you gotta
do is click the Subscribe button and
ring the bell below this video to stay
up to date with all my content and if
you want even more you can watch or
listen to my show at the delaware.com
Spotify or apple podcast looking forward
to welcoming you to the Sweet Baby gang